domenico quirico aux journalistes est la
stampa bonsoir domenico quirico ce
triste constat effectivement plus de
morts en italie qu'en chine comment
réagit-on en italie à ce diagnostic
la situation est terrible surtout dans
les régions du nord la lombardie veneto
et les milliers romagne qui il sent les
gens plus moderne plus organiser des
pays mais sont les plus touchées de la
pandémie
le grand problème c'est le sud où là la
santé publique est très mal passée et
donc on peut c'est si la pandémie va
toucher le sud du pays
c'est vraiment un grand problème tout le
tout le gouvernement a pris des
décisions du rectorat dur à fermer à
fermer tous les écoles les cafés le
sport et c'est beaucoup deux entreprises
sont fermées mais le nombre de
contaminés va embêter et c'est pas on ne
peut pas prévoir à quelle date
pour terminer il ya une inversion de la
courbe est ce que c'est un espoir en
italien on estime qu'on est dans le pic
et que les choses vont aller mieux où on
reste très prudent il faut être très
très prudent on disait qu'ils dans cette
semaine c'était possible qui bakkali le
nombre des quotas minimes et c'est
pareil
les membres sans intérêt de motets les
le problème en italie c'est qui la
population est trop vieux lilian par
chantage de population très vieux donc
plus touchés par la par la pandémie et
sauve a expliqué le nombre de noms qui
est vraiment terrible
vraiment terrible il ya une prolongation
des mesures de confinement on pouvait
s'y attendre comment ont réagi les
italiens c'est quelque chose qui qu'ils
vivent difficilement comme nous le
rappelait notre invité espagnol tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que ce sont des
cultures on aime se retrouver dans la
rue c'est une culture très très
convivial où les gens ne sont pas chacun
de leur côté comment le vivent t-il bon
le pôle est qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
monde dans les rues
il ya beaucoup de monde qui va faire du
sport qui va faire du jogging qui va
dans les parcs publics pour pour et
surtout les jeunes
au début on pensait que c'était une
chose en grippe
pas plus et s était une erreur
aujourd'hui les rues sombres sont encore
avec beaucoup de voitures
il y a la permission qui on va signer
moi-même soi même mais c'est pas bon ça
parce que soto à nîmes il ya aux magnans
new baby les gouverneurs bon à fermer
vraiment tout et c'est peut-être que
bien la décision vient à venir mais
domenico quirico justement je vous
entends et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
inquiétant lors on ne dit pas forcément
qu'on fait mieux en france a la preuve
aujourd'hui on a fait fermer les plages
mais est ce que ce n'est pas là le
problème justement peut-être que les
italiens ne respecte pas assez
strictement les mesures on rappelle
qu'en chine il n'est plus patient faire
plus patient pardon plus de cas nouveaux
apparemment d'après ce qu'on nous dit
mais il ya eu d un confinement très
stricte des mesures draconiennes alors
le problème que c'est la sinne c'est une
dictature c'est pas
ainsi donc c'est plus facile il faut il
faut avant de fermer les libertés
individuelles
il faut être très très prudent très
prudent
pour quelles raisons vous pensez que ce
n'est pas souhaitable
aujourd'hui dans des démocraties sa
pause
et peut-être effectivement un problème
de philosophie ou empêcher à tout le
monde de sortir de la maison il faut
faire des lois et c'est pas une chose
quand parité avec indifférence
il faut méditer beaucoup je pense vous
pensez que les italiens ne sont pas
prêts à ça quand qu'il s'agit peut-être
d'une question de vie ou de mort
beaucoup de leurs concitoyens je pense
que nous disent open merci beaucoup en
tout cas dominicaux quirico d'avoir été
avec nos journalistes à la stampa
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france nous
avoir parlé donc de la situation en
italie